des socialistes municipaux et j'essaie
d'en faire une une conjonction pour
comprendre comment la gauche a pu
évoluer de décennies en décennie et
comment en est-on arrivé là aujourd'hui
ce qui nous amène à un portrait critique
de ce qu'est la gauche contemporaine la
gauche est devenue depuis Mitterrand le
parti de l'étranger et des minorités
commentaires dans l'internaute on va
revenir sur cette question parce que
c'est aussi un peu le fond de votre
ouvrage vous parlez des intellectuels de
gauche vous avez cité Jaurès on pourrait
citer Émile Zola Marx par exemple
pourtant vous pour vous c'est celui qui
votre premier idole de gauche rien à
voir avec tout ça c'est un personnage de
BD racontez oui c'est rarement c'est le
fils déjà je farouche alors ça c'est
assez amusant parce qu'effectivement
quand vous avez 8 ans 10 ans 12 ans vous
commencez un peu votre vie on vous amène
à la gauche non pas via effectivement je
reste ou en vous lisant Zola sauf à ce
que vous soyez vraiment surdoué on
arrive on arrive à cette maturité cette
conscience politique un peu plus tard
mais d'abord par Rahan par la bande
était distribués avec l'humanité
dimanche avec pill gadget c'était ce
qu'on donnait aux enfants et ce qui est
intéressant je fais une petite analyse
de cette bande dessinée c'est qu'elle
était à la fois politique à la fois
ludique mais elle était surtout elle
avait une portée politique Rahan était
une sorte de personnage si vous voulez
qui arrivait dans les villages et qu'il
est délivré de l'oppression souvent d'un
chef qui a bien des égards faisait
penser à la phrase de Marx l'opium du
peuple la religion du peuple et donc il
arrivait Rahan et puis il proposait
toutes sortes d'innovations c'est une
sorte de héros viril blond qui
ressemblait et d'ailleurs le l'auteur de
Rahan c'est ce que je raconte dans mon
livre avait fait une sorte de Gaulois si
vous voulez blond aux yeux bleus plutôt
costaud à une sorte l'antithèse de
l'homme déconstruit madame Rousseau et
puis il arrivait et il s'en venait
libérer les peuples opprimés c'était ça
la première icône de gauche que j'ai
côtoyé après ça a été le Spartacus de
Kubrick jouait par cœur Douglas ça a été
toutes sortes de choses qui sont plus de
l'ordre et là on revient à notre
discussion du début plus de l'ordre de
l'affectif que de l'ordre du théorique
après de fait une fois que vous êtes un
peu plus vieux et que vous vous
intéressez à l'histoire des idées vous
comprenez le prolétariat du 19e siècle à
travers les textes de Zola effectivement
avec des descriptions qui vous donnent
de façon très fine ce que pouvait être
la vie du petit peuple de France au 19e
siècle en pleine révolution industrielle
alors vous votre vie ça a débuté à
Bordeaux dans le bordeaux d'Alain Juppé
le Bègue également entre le bordeaux
d'Alain Juppé et le bec de Noël Mamère
vous parliez de votre relation avec
votre père avec qui vous faisiez les
marchés le samedi matin cette gauche de
votre enfance justement quel était telle
pourquoi vous manque-t-elle tant
aujourd'hui elle me manque alors comme
je suis assez jeune elle a pas
radicalement changé disons que moi
j'étais dans une sorte de cocon par
rapport à ce que la gauche avait déjà
commencé à être puisque je daterais le
grand virage de la gauche à 1983 1984
le tournant de la rigueur et
effectivement la nomination de Laurent
Fabius à la place de Pierre Mauroy mais
lorsque qu'est-ce qui vous touchez dans
cette gauche qui vous manque aujourd'hui
il y avait quelque chose qui me touchait
qui était incroyable et j'en parle
largement dans le livre c'était toute
cette dimension justement
patriotique ce rapport au territoire
nous faisions beaucoup avec mes parents
de tourisme vert et nous étions de cette
gauche qu'on qualifierait de provinciale
d'enraciner de patriotes et donc j'ai
appris à aimer la gauche en même temps
que j'ai appris à aimer la France et si
vous voulez l'un et l'autre elle est
ensemble et il y a pas là-dedans une
forme d'hédonisme déconnectée puisque
c'est l'histoire même de ma vie de mon
enfance et c'est pour ça que je la
raconte un petit peu dans ce livre et
effectivement il y avait aussi l'idée
d'être bercé par le récit des anciens
des ancêtres mais je parle un peu de ma
grand-mère paternelle qui était
concierge dans le Paris des années 50 40
ils ont été juste d'ailleurs pendant
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
puis après il y a eu effectivement ce
moment où ils sont allés en HLM autour
de
propose dans le livre cet homme
petriculture dont on sait que
intellectuellement parlant son chemin
c'est plutôt fait de la droite voire de
l'extrême droite à la gauche et que les
grandes réformes de la gauche sociale de
François Mitterrand à part effectivement
entre 1981 et 1983 et la nationalisé je
ne sais plus combien de banques etc etc
globalement très vite il a laissé
l'économie à Jacques Attali il a
embrassé à ses mollement à ses
timidement les tests de Thatcher de
Regan qui était en cours à l'époque et
puis peu à peu il s'est déporté sur le
sociétal ça a été un de ses premiers
présidents des dynasties que j'appelle
dans mon livre la dynastie des
présidents mondialistes et je parle de
dynastie des présidents mondialiste à
partir de Giscard à peu près et depuis
Giscard et bien effectivement François
Mitterrand Jacques Chirac Lionel Jospin
Nicolas Sarkozy puis François Hollande
et bien sûr Emmanuel Macron qu'une
version paroxystique ont tous été
mondialistes européistes plutôt
favorable à une immigration assez
massive et donc finalement il y a une
forme de cohérence idéologique de la
part de tous ces présidents qui ont fait
valser si je puis dire et et Emmanuel
Macron surtout le clivage gauche-droite
dans ce dans son assise idéologique
alors j'entends ce que vous dites mais
sur François Mitterrand par exemple
lorsqu'il fait le tournant de la rigueur
en 1983 est-ce qu'il se heurte pas tout
simplement au principe de réalité c'est
ça qui est intéressant il y a 400
milliards de déficits de dettes
lorsqu'il part enfin lorsqu'il part vers
le tournoi de la rigueur en 84 c'est à
dire que il lago gauche lorsqu'elle fait
l'expérience du réel des réalités
économiques entre 81 et le tournant de
la rigueur s'aperçoit que le seul
raisonnement marxiste voire keynésien ne
suffit pas à entendre les enjeux du
monde contemporain et c'est à ce
moment-là qui aurait dû y avoir une
refonte du logiciel idéologique c'est
pas parce que lorsque vous avez essayé
l'idéologie keynésienne au plan
économique la théorie keynésienne en
économie ou la théorie marxiste et que
ça ne marche pas qu'il faut
nécessairement embrasser la
financarisation du monde et le
capitalisme moderne contemporain le
néolibéralisme typiquement lorsque je
parle un peu dans mon livre du
capitalisme paternaliste de De Gaulle de
son protectionnisme de sa façon de
concevoir les rapports entre les
richesses et la pauvreté entre le
travail et le capital il y avait là une
forme d'équilibre que de Gaulle a très
bien trouvé par exemple au plan
institutionnel dans la 5ème République
entre l'Ancien Régime et la Révolution
c'est si vous voulez l'art de gouverner
en homme d'État c'est précisément de
capter ses équilibres et la gauche n'a
pas su le capter tentez si bien
qu'aujourd'hui elle illustre son
impéritie en matière économique
lorsqu'elle est aux affaires et donc
elle se déporte timidement sur les
thèses néolibérales sans véritablement
les faire siennes c'était ces temps cela
que je moi je fais ce reproche à la
gauche d'une forme de paresse
intellectuelle sur les sujets
économiques alors on se souvient
pourtant de la campagne par exemple de
2012 François Hollande au Bourget mon
ennemi c'est le monde de la finance
est-ce que cette dialogue dialectique de
Gauche anticapitaliste anti ordre établi
est-ce qu'elle n'existe pas encore
malgré tout
les Chinois feraient des paires
chaussettes et puis nous nous ferions la
conceptualisation des Airbus en Europe
ça n'a pas marché nous avons des
industrialisés et cette
désindustrialisation là par exemple elle
nous a conduit à aller dans le mur
économique de la part de la droite
libérale tendance UDF orléaniste comme
de la part de la gauche libérale
social-démocrate donc les échecs
économiques moi je veux pas les
attribuer seulement à la gauche dans mon
lit je les attribue à la gauche au
pouvoir et à la droite au pouvoir et je
pense que précisément il y a un autre
chemin entre une lutte un peu facile
contre le capitalisme qui ne propose
absolument d'aucune alternative
suivez mon regard je parle un peu de la
nups entre autres et qui nous dit
seulement il faut augmenter les salaires
il faut augmenter le SMIC mais alors
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
l'industrialiser le pays pas vraiment de
solution que fait-on en matière de
protectionnisme ou pas il y a pas
vraiment de solution doit-on passer par
la démondialisation à part nos Mambourg
qui avait un discours très cohérent sur
le sujet moi je vois pas tellement
d'alternatives voyez donc cette forme de
paresse intellectuelle sur les sujets
économiques à gauche me dés et j'essaie
de lancer un appel aussi dans ce livre à
une refonte du logiciel sur ce point de
vue là je vous cite Paul Melun le
poulailler était aussi le repère de
toute la gauche béglaise le poulailler
c'est le bistrot à côté du marché dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure avec votre
père le monde diplôme ou l'Huma dimanche
traînais négligemment sur les tables on
y aurait jamais vu le Figaro journal
bourgeois je vous remercie pour le
compliment c'était je crois que je n'ai
pas ce que mis entre guillemets oui
c'était voilà je crois que c'est du
guillemets effectivement bon quoi qu'il
en soit est-ce qu'il y avait pas une
forme de une forme de sectarisme dans
cette gauche que vous décrivez oui et
alors le secrétisme prend une place tout
à fait importante au marché j'en parle
dans quelques lignes après le passage
que vous citez là un jour j'étais avec
mon père sur le stand on vendait nos
légumes puis c'est le moment d'une
campagne je crois pour les régionales et
arrive un candidat de du l'UMP à
l'époque des républicains qui arrivent
pour tracter sur le marché pour son
candidat puis mon père tout de suite
bonne tradition d'une certaine gauche
qui dit fiche le camp d'ici je vous le
fais en langage plus plus fleuri mais
enfin bon voilà si je le ici t'as rien à
faire là tu es de droite etc donc le
gars s'en va et puis quelques jours plus
tard et puis les gens qui étaient autour
du stand qui étaient plutôt de gauche
communiste etc pareil sans son prix elle
fuit et quelques mois plus tard et bien
on a eu besoin d'un deuxième parasol
parce qu'ils étaient très mauvais pour
couvrir notre stand et mon père est allé
demander à quelqu'un et cet homme-là qui
figurez-vous avec qui qu'on avait
houstillé qui avait plutôt le cœur sur
la main vous avez prêté le parasol était
venu nous était venu en aide et mon père
et lui finir ta mis ça qui est
l'histoire assez amusante c'est que
finalement ce que j'explique dans ce
livre à travers cette anecdote et et
tout un tas d'autres éléments c'est
qu'il faut aller par de là à mon sens un
clivage qui aujourd'hui n'a plus court
entre un gaullisme social une droite
sociale un gaullisme catholique ancré
dans les territoires plein de plein de
facettes différentes et la gauche
patriote la gauche populaire je pense
qu'il y a des jonctions intellectuelles
idéologique profonde et qu'il y a un
amour de la France en commun entre ces
deux facettes une même pièce qui
s'appelle la France et que voilà je
pense il y a vraiment un appel à ça
alors après le sectarisme
malheureusement il existe des deux côtés
moi j'essaie de conjurer ça et d'être
dans une posture plus gaulienne c'est là
moi aussi ma tradition politique je suis
gaulliste de gauche c'est ça qui me
fascine dans dans les débats dans les
échanges et je me désole que
effectivement il est temps de sectarisme
de part et d'autre de l'échiquier
politique ça c'est une évidence alors
très très rapidement pomelin si vous
voulez bien parce que le temps passe
vite on se souvient de la poste par
exemple de Manuel Valls alors Premier
ministre sur l'existence de ces deux
gauches irrégonciliables est-ce que vous
croyez vous aussi comme l'affirme
certains que le clivage gauche droite et
dépassé alors sur les deux gauchers
réconciliables de Manuel Valls moi j'en
ajoute même une troisième ça
effectivement je pense qu'il y a la
gauche social-démocrate sociale libéral
de Manuel Valls et qui a la gauche de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la nupaise je
qualifierais plutôt l'islamo-gauchiste
mais qu'il en existe une troisième une
gauche populaire patriote enracinée elle
peut être beaucoup souverainiste
effectivement je vais de moi qui suis
chevènementiste c'est plutôt la main
gauche voilà là-dessus ensuite sur les
clivages bah le clivage gauche-droite il
a vocation il a pas vocation à
disparaître à parler du clivage entre
les mondialistes et les patriotes ou le
camp national moi je pense que les
clivages se superposent ils ne s'annule
pas je pense qu'on peut continuer à
faire vivre dans ce pays un clivage
intellectuel une mise en tension
intellectuelle entre la gauche et la
droite intellectuellement c'est
pertinent vous pouvez avoir des comment
dire des ascendants philosophiques
théoriques politique morale qui peuvent
être différentes selon que vous veniez
de la gauche ou à droite par contre les
clivage se superposent le clivage entre
mondialiste et patriote ce superposent à
celui là et c'est précisément dans la
conjonction de ses clivages qu'on peut
penser le monde de demain donc je pense
que le clivage gauche droite est une est
une clé d'entrée mais les choses doivent
pas se résumer à cela et il faut savoir
à mon sens unir les défenseurs du du
patriotisme de gauche et de droite des
deux rivages comme on dit c'est ce qui
avait tenté de faire d'ailleurs
vainement Jean-Pierre Chevènement c'est
une vieille histoire mais je pense
toujours à cela moi
[Musique]